okay so this might have been Part A Part
B why don't I ask you do now as part see
where is this gonna go is we're going to
use this graph again and we don't need
to do any more drawing we can say hence
solve the antigen I have X minus 2 is
less than 5 okay now again if that was
the first question that you saw without
any of the other context you could have
just solved this algebraically but we've
done all of the work on the graph to
work out what this means right now you
know how we translated this equation
into words we said oh when you read that
what you should be thinking is when does
this graph intersect with this value
well down here I'm gonna take all that
same knowledge but I'm gonna just subtly
shift it for the only the single change
I've made right this question is asking
when does this graph not intersect but
when is it lesser than that's below when
is it below 5 right now you can actually
see maybe if you have a highlighter or
something like that you can actually
highlight the part of the graph that's
below rastan did you have a question or
thought yeah you're okay
right I happy if you'd asked you can say
this is the partisan exactly what are
you thinking that yeah that's a really
good question how do we know that the 5
is looking for like this vertical thing
rather than like how do I know it's not
like x equals 5 right let me show you
what we're comparing is y equals this
and so if we're making this equal to Y
we have to make the right-hand side also
equal to Y so we're comparing like
apples and apples as it were so that's
why if I'm thinking of both of them as
Y's then I can solve visually ok did you
come back to your question or Jemaine
what are you thinking okay so what we're
thinking of here is if you've got given
a series of questions that are all sort
of building off each other so if this is
Part A and then this is Part B we can
use Part A and B to solve C which is
sort of its own question all on its own
right so it's not like this question and
this question are the same question but
I can use my answer to this question to
solve this question
right so it's like a subsequent thing I
might get asked does that make sense so
I'm I'm posing this question to as a
whole separate question it's not the
same question they're actually separate
things that I'm asking okay so you can
see if that's okay what do you drink do
you all know something yeah yeah go
ahead yep yeah yes so that's a really
good question because I've used the word
hence right again that's forcing you to
use what came before um occasionally
you'll see a phrase which is not hence
but hence or otherwise which means you
know what we've tried to hold your hand
and give you some tips give you some
guideposts but you can solve it however
way you want but if they've said hence
and there's nothing else you must use
what's there which means look show me on
the graph that you have just drawn show
me what this means visually and that
means the part that is underneath and
this is literally something like what I
would draw
okay so we got solutions of X equals 7
and x equals negative 3 before but now
I'm solving an inequality so my answer
should also be an inequality right so
where is it where's it happening okay so
I could split this off into a couple of
cases that's what you're thinking of
like I think of the positive part and I
think of the negative part but in some
ways visually we've kind of already done
that here's the positive part and here's
the negative part so this is actually
one of the advantages of graphing you
know long you've kind of already done it
yeah you just defined oh where are these
green values these green dots where do
they sit between and the answer is
between this answer you found before and
between that answer you found before
right so you've done all of the work
so our answer to this question solve
this is x equals negative 3 unless you
or x equals 7 our answer to this
question is between negative 3 & 7
that's where X is allowed to go we could
answer this in two different ways we
could use inequality or notation or we
could use interval notation this is
written as an inequality so maybe we
write it that way first
to say I'm between negative three and
seven how do I write this we're gonna
write yet it's on perfect that's it
that's the solution just for the sake of
because we can let's also write interval
notation it's kind of handy I could say
X belongs to what interval am I going to
do square brackets or like round
parenthesis these ones are these ones
around because the boundaries negative
three and seven they're not actually
included do you see that right so I'm
actually gonna have to say he's my round
little brackets and then I just put my
numbers just like I did before
from negative 3 to 7 okay and one of
ways you can know that is like oh do I
include my boundaries or not well if I
picked an actual value like negative 3
now let's pick an easy value 7 things
stay positive okay if I go here and put
that value x equals 7m right does it
actually work well is the absolute value
of 7 minus 2 what's that equal to that's
equal to the absolute value of 5 which
is 5 is 5 less than 5 last I checked it
was not so since it doesn't that value 7
doesn't satisfy I can't include it in my
interval I can include in my inequality
that makes sense